[Music]
hi I'm skip Ellis he's not
I'm Shannon Sharpe we're from undisputed
we're gonna be on this week's episode of
truth or dab and I do not think he can
take the heat I'm going to tell the
truth
you'll probably Babylon
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
hot one special we give our guests two
simple options tell the truth or suffer
the wrath of the last app today I'm
excited to welcome Skip Bayless and
Shannon Sharpe the former is an
award-winning journalist TV host and
author the latter is a three-time Super
Bowl champion and Pro Football Hall of
Famer together they lead skip and shin
and undisputed FS ones opinion and
debate show moderated by Jenny Taft
catch up weekdays at 9:30 a.m. Eastern
on Fox Sports 1
Shannon skip welcome to the show thank
you thanks for having thank you alright
so before we get started I want to break
things down in front of you you guys
have three scorching hot chicken wings
that have all been doused in various
versions of the last AB of a series of
deeply personal potentially awkward
questions for each of you and when I ask
you a question you have a choice answer
it honestly or escape the truth by
eating a death wing you guys ready to
get started
oh quick story sure once upon a time my
father owned a little hole-in-the-wall
barbecue restaurant on the wrong side
the south side of Oklahoma City he made
me work there when I as soon as I was 4
years of age and the the whole option
there was either hot or mild sauce so
when I was 4 years of age I took my
first shot at hot sauce and it wiped me
out and I've never even tried it since
then so this will be my first foray back
into hot sauce
this feels like a day with some serious
weight almost historical yep yeah I
don't I don't do well with hot either
this is gonna be I'm literally there's a
possibility I can throw up let me put
you guys at ease here in round 1 because
I don't think any wings are flying off
the board all I'm gonna do here is throw
out some general debate topics and I'll
GP just like this show you know if you
can take a position or have an opinion
you'll get out of round one no problem
ok ok so first up is this here's the
debate question I posed to you guys and
just like the show you know just take
aside ok
our eSports a real sport and if so would
you consider someone like ninja to be a
professional athlete
I know who ninja is I follow him on IG
and on Twitter you do I do I do know who
ninja is also know who Booga is I'm
gonna say yes it is a sport if you
notice Michael Jordan is bought into it
mr. Kraft has bought into an eSport team
so yes it is more like we do not follow
ninja but is and I'm going a big no it
is not a sport it's a skill but it's not
a sport because there's no real
athleticism to it there's no full body
use at all
it is reaction time obviously mine is a
sport of midnight board well then you'd
lose that one all right one more for you
guys if you were the major league
baseball commissioner what do you think
is a just and fair punishment for the
Astros tipping pitches by banging on
trash cans hmm punishment should be
severe it should be swift and it should
be harsh because it's not only to punish
the offender it's also to deter others
from doing a message so general manager
he's gonna get at the bare minimum two
years and probably a ten million dollar
fine and I'm making people to lose their
job you gotta lose your job Sportster
yes absolutely
let's get what you think no punishment
what cheating has been part of the
fabric of America's pastime since the
1890s
it's what it is it's what everybody if
you ain't cheating you ain't tryin
that's the oldest mantra in the sport of
baseball well you should they're helpful
you think that's on a hill you have to
guard your signals better or change your
signals you can also mix them up and mix
up the opponent no I mean if you can if
you can decipher you kitchen have
cameras helping your skill that's
cheating hmm it's getting hot in here
but it's just heated debate and round
one no wings off the board as I expected
and on to round two skip this question
is for you okay the relationship that
you have with Lil Wayne it's the stuff
of legend from him doing the intro song
for
disputed to the drip Bayliss nickname
and I know that you guys stay in close
contact even when he's not a guest on
the show that is true can you share the
last text message exchange that you've
had with Lil Wayne for our viewers
watching that absolutely I'll do two in
a row his two nights ago when one night
ago two nights ago he had just returned
from playing his first and probably only
gig in Saudi Arabia and it was over the
Thanksgiving holiday and we must have
texted 20 times back and forth about
what Saudi Arabia was really like and he
did say a guy named his Excellency had
come to his hotel suite and promised to
send him either a Ferrari or a
Lamborghini which would you like Wayne
and he said I'll take a Lambo and the
guy said it'll be at your doorstep in
three weeks in Miami so that's the first
one and then just happened that
yesterday was my birthday and he sent me
actually Debra he told me when we're in
Miami for the Superbowl where he
obviously lives
he said the Lambo is yours so Wow just
for the week happy birthday saying happy
birthday Shannon to you I know that you
guys are in the collet how you see it
double down business but no one can
shoot a hundred percent from the field
is there a take an opinion that you'd
like to walk back right now either gallu
time for him you think that you were
wrong or because the smoke that you got
from whatever you said just wasn't worth
it no no there's a lot of thought when I
say something there's a lot of fun
I just don't just fly up to Hamel
officers I've given a lot of thought and
consideration so no I don't walk
anything back hmm
you should eat a wing for that for what
what I need to water your wrong opinions
you have tried to retire Tom Brady for
three straight years this is it it's
over he's washed up so time so Tom
Brady's gonna be an MVP discussion well
again he's still afloat and I believe
he'll be New England's quarterback next
year and you have now sort of edited
your opinion down to well he's not going
to be New England's quarterback he'll be
a quarterback the walls are closing in
Shannon I'm not taking anything back eat
a wing hello you not the hole anyway
that's like s there what there we go
yeah that's what I'm guessing this party
started
Shannon not good with hot sauce mm-hmm
don't go well now that I hate to be the
beef dude I'm almost certain I had to
bigger piece that's that can that
competitive spirit coming through that's
why you lift all that oh all right well
I got the whole go fit me right now big
two rounds down three to go skip going
back to you yes sir
you guys have had a ton of celebrity
guests and undisputed from former
athletes to celebrities like 2 Chainz
and Kevin Hart and many more
looking back who would you say was the
least prepared weakest debater that
you've ever had in that guest seat on
undisputed I would say I'm gonna have to
go back to the old show that I was on
a man Fabolous got no sports knowledge
at all he was struggling from question
number one but he's a guy you don't want
to mess with so you don't really
challenge him on the air or maybe he
would challenge you off the air well you
just did you know I had to break it to
you skip but you just did the Internet
people on yes
shann straight to the point right to the
point careful around the eyes who was a
more inspiring locker room leader Ray
Lewis or John Elway good question John
was not very he didn't give a whole lot
that was my job my job was to get the
guys ready to play obviously Ray in 100
year history might be one of the top two
or three motivational inspiring he'd
have you wanted to run through it he's
very Baptist minister military general
he's all those things rolled into one
he made you got you fired up mmm I think
you're fired up now yeah yeah I'm sorry
John but Ray got this look John it's not
gonna return your calls anymore okay I
won't be able to talk anyway so all
right on to number four skip which team
has the most insufferable fan base in
all of professional sports and what do
you think it is about that city or group
of people that makes them the worst yeah
you know what you you think you know
what I'm gonna say I know the correct
answer is
okay I'll call him out and I'm one of
them so at least I'm not being a
hypocrite here it's that Dallas Cowboys
it's America's Team I was basically born
and raised a cowboy fan and I will admit
it I am insufferable when it comes to
the Dallas Cowboys I was taken by my
uncle in Dallas Texas to my first game
when I was 10 years of age at the old
Cotton Bowl where they used to play and
they played a team that was then called
the st. Louis Cardinals just like the
st. Louis Cardinals baseball team and
the Cardinals did win that game against
the expansion Dallas Cowboys but I was
hooked and cowboy fans overreact one way
or the other
every Sunday they're called blue Mondays
in Dallas when they lose and we have
blue Mondays on undisputed when I lose
you I despise it well blue Fridays it
could be tonight or tonight party
tonight would be right I even suggested
a I just might not come to work tomorrow
if they lose to the Chicago Bears you
being should I know I know yeah but it's
got potential
Shanon yes I read that you'll sometimes
mute the TV when you're watching a
football game yes you don't want your
opinion to be swayed one way or the
other based on the color commentary yeah
but I'm curious who do you mute when the
game is over give us an on-air NFL
personality who you'd mute when the game
is over someone you're just not
interested in here okay Wow any time
he's on time you Wow
you can be telling me I won ten million
dollars I'll never know I won't pick
that Preiser him for sure all right
moving on to the last round and you know
we've been talking a lot of fire today
this is the part of the show it's the
end the end of the road and we're just
gonna pit our guests against each other
to see if they'll sell each other out to
avoid eating a death wing my guess is
they probably will first up Shannon yes
what's one thing internet trolls get
right about skip everything
ah daddy hates LeBron thank you
he sincerely believed that LeBron is he
thinks LeBron is great don't get me
wrong he thinks LeBron is great but he
thinks Kobe he thinks Michael Jordan
Larry Bird are just greater it he's
terribly terribly sadly mistaken
you mentioned three humans who are all
mentally tougher in the clutch than
LeBron James is thank you
and it always gets me that you're the
biggest LeBron fan on the planet because
he's the one guy I would think that you
would not have great respect for and you
you like stalk him you're just like his
biggest groupie fan and the history of
fandom am i right no okay maybe slightly
we possibly deal but that's not that's
not what he had that weathered equation
he possibly gives you new LeBrons this
and that shoes and jerseys and write
signed jerseys yeah yeah no you wear
them on the air it's obvious well that's
what has been so exciting for me in this
show you know sometimes people eat the
wings cuz they want to dodge it not you
guys I don't think I think we could
probably be here all night and not
finish these wings but here it is the
last questions skip what is Shannon's
biggest weakness as an on-air
personality
[Music]
fallen on the grenade I don't want to
give up trade secrets because I've won
every debate in the history of
undisputed so why would I reveal my
strategy I'm not I'm just gonna take it
I'm gonna take the bullet so that I can
win every debate tomorrow what am I
supposed to do if he's not telling the
truth because he's not telling the truth
I'm gonna do this whoa it's a
wing-eating bonanza here in the fifth
and final round skip you haven't had hot
sauce since what you were four years old
this is my first foray back into it you
know what is it like - I just found a
whole new world I think I'm good with it
once again proving I'm tougher than
Shannon Sharpe I could have done that
all right we'll find out for real
weekdays 9:30 a.m. Eastern on FS 1
fellas thank you so much truth are dev
another one in the books our last shoot
of 2019 - so - all the hot ones fans the
first group these people have been
watching us for so long thank you so
much and happy new year it's been a
wonderful year
Shannon skip anything you guys want to
say before we get you right to a nice
bath what oh I don't know what y'all
deal with these but this is it don't try
and seal do y'all know y'all get sued
y'all silly it was an honor to beat down
my man Shannon Sharpe on truth or dab
the way I do I'm dispute it every day
thank hey I'm the shears too
way to go hey congratulations all your
success thank you very much big fan too
so it was really awesome for us to eg as
in here and that went exactly how I
thought it would okay hey what's going
on hot ones fans this is Sean Evans
checking in and do you smell that winter
it's in the air no I'm not talking about
eggnog I'm not talking about candy canes
I am talking about the last dab xxx
because the pepper acts harvest it's in
baby this is the hottest hot sauce that
we've ever made with three kinds of
pepper acts I'm talking chocolate X I'm
talking mustard X I'm talking peach X
the last dab XXX it's available now at
Heaton Escom Heat miss calm to order the
hottest hot sauce that we've ever made
Wawa why is he shaking that bottle
[Music]